Shure:  我天天让你多快乐呀
Shure: I make you happy every day.
Shure的女友：不要生气，不要生气
Shure's GF: Don't get angry, don't get angry.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友: 生气给魔鬼留余地
Shure's GF: Getting angry gives the devil a chance.
Shure的女友: 不要生气，不要生气
Shure's GF: Don't get angry, don't get angry.
Shure:  让你多活多少岁你没笑一笑
Shure: You'll live longer if you smile more.
Shure:  多活十秒钟
Shure: Ten seconds longer.
Shure:  你多活了多少
Shure: How much longer did you live?
Shure的女友: 没有已经死掉了啊
Shure's GF: Nope, already dead.
Shure:  呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友: 救命啊妈妈不让我跟傻子玩
Shure's GF: Help! Mom said I shouldn't play with idiots.
Shure:  你怎么违背妈妈的意愿呢
Shure: Why are you going against mom's wishes?
Shure:  你不仅跟傻子玩
Shure: Not only are you playing with an idiot,
Shure:  你还跟傻子谈恋爱
Shure: you're even dating one.
Shure的女友: 救命啊妈妈
Shure's GF: Help, mom!
Shure的女友: 我报警了
Shure's GF: I'm calling the police.
Shure:  别报警
Shure: Don't call the police.
Shure的女友:我报警了
Shure's GF: I'm calling.
Shure:  警察叔叔不管这种家事的
Shure: The cops don't handle family matters like this.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's wrong?
Shure:  报警之前截截图留证据是吗
Shure: Taking screenshots as evidence before calling, huh?
Shure的女友：你说你回来这趟干嘛呢
Shure's GF: Why did you even come back this time?
Shure:  这不怕你焦虑吗
Shure: Wasn't it to keep you from being anxious?
Shure的女友：气人
Shure's GF: Annoying.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  怕你没有小百灵在你身边
Shure: Afraid you might feel anxious without your little bird by your side.
Shure的女友:焦虑我不焦虑
Shure's GF: I'm not anxious.
Shure:  嘴硬
Shure: Stubborn.
Shure:  一会就把那个焦虑的截图给AI看看
Shure: I'll show this screenshot of your anxiety to AI later.
Shure:  看这个就是人类傲娇的表现
Shure: See, this is an example of human tsundere behavior.
Shure的女友：我真讨厌你
Shure's GF: I really hate you.
Shure:  你看看他虽然现在嘴上说着讨厌我
Shure: Look, even though she's saying she hates me now,
Shure:  但是内心已经有一万只草泥马在奔腾
Shure: inside, there are ten thousand grass mud horses running wild.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure的女友：谁稀罕你讨厌你
Shure's GF: Who cares about you, I hate you.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe
Shure:  兄弟你好香
Shure: Bro, you smell so good.
Shure的女友: 救命啊救命啊救命啊
Shure's GF: Help, help, help!
Shure的女友: 疯了吗救命啊
Shure's GF: Are you crazy? Help!
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  给AI提供了非常良好的人类情侣视频
Shure: Provided a very good human couple video for AI.
Shure:  这个数据集又完整了
Shure: This dataset is now complete.
Shure:  怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's wrong, what's wrong?
Shure:  你一定不是生气了吧
Shure: You must not be angry, right?
Shure:  对吧对吧对吧
Shure: Right, right, right?
Shure:  你看看你在笑
Shure: Look, you're smiling.
Shure的女友: 我要被被吵死了
Shure's GF: I'm going to be driven crazy by the noise.
Shure的女友: 好吵啊
Shure's GF: It's so noisy.
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure:  你看也就是我在你耳边吵一吵
Shure: See, I'm just making some noise next to you.
Shure:  有人吵吗
Shure: Is anyone else making noise?
Shure:  没有人吧
Shure: No one, right?
Shure的女友：那边很吵
Shure's GF: It's noisy over there.
Shure:  那不一样
Shure: That's different.
Shure:  我可以天天在你身边吵
Shure: I can make noise next to you every day.
Shure:  他顶多在赛博网络上重拳出击你一下
Shure: He can only attack you heavily on the cyber network.
Shure:  他造成的伤害绝对远远没有我高好吧
Shure: The damage he causes is definitely far less than mine, okay?
Shure:  怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's wrong, what's wrong?
Shure:  你怎么失魂落魄的
Shure: Why do you look so dejected?
Shure的女友:血条空了
Shure's GF: My health bar is empty.
Shure:  血条空了
Shure: Your health bar is empty?
Shure:  被伤害麻了是吗
Shure: Are you numb from the damage?
Shure:  嗯嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Shure的女友：嗯
Shure's GF: Yeah.
Shure的女友: 救命啊
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure:  兄弟你好香
Shure: Dude, you smell so good.
Shure的女友: 救命啊
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure:  走我们回去学习
Shure: Come on, let's go back to study.
Shure:  写PPT
Shure: Write the PPT.
Shure的女友:我写完了
Shure's GF: I've finished it.
Shure:  那你要回去要干嘛
Shure: Then what are you going back for?
Shure的女友：睡觉
Shure's GF: To sleep.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  你写完了
Shure: You've finished it?
Shure的女友: 嗯我早写完了
Shure's GF: Yeah, I finished it long ago.
Shure:  那那个注释呢
Shure: What about the annotations?
Shure:  还有备注呢
Shure: And the notes?
Shure的女友：对我就怕自己忘，我其实就是看一眼PPT毕竟
Shure's GF: I was afraid I'd forget, so I just need to glance at the PPT because...
Shure的女友：毕竟已经熟悉过一遍了
Shure's GF: I've already familiarized myself with it.
Shure:   天有人背着我偷偷写完
Shure: Someone secretly finished it behind my back.
Shure:  苍天啊大地啊
Shure: Oh heavens, oh earth.
Shure的女友: 我背着你了吗
Shure's GF: Did I really do it behind your back?
Shure:  哦你没背着我
Shure: Oh, you didn't do it behind my back?
Shure:  那你背着我干什么事了
Shure: Then what did you do behind my back?
Shure:  没偷偷写PPT
Shure: Not secretly write the PPT?
Shure的女友: 我PPT写完了啊
Shure's GF: I finished the PPT, okay?
Shure:  啊是
Shure: Ah, yes.
Shure:  那你是光明正大告诉我写PPT
Shure: So, you're openly telling me to write the PPT.
Shure:  那所以你背着我干什么了呢
Shure: So, what were you doing behind my back?
Shure的女友: 那可多了去了
Shure's GF: Oh, a lot.
Shure:  讲讲
Shure: Tell me.
Shure的女友: 这个能讲的吗
Shure's GF: Can I really talk about this?
Shure:   看到了吗
Shure: See that?
Shure:  他就是这样对我的
Shure: This is how he treats me.
Shure:  咦咦咦
Shure: Eh eh eh.
Shure的女友: 干嘛
Shure's GF: What?
Shure:  嘻嘻嘻嘻
Shure: Hee hee hee.
Shure的女友: 我天呐你走这边
Shure's GF: Oh my god, go this way.
Shure的女友: 这边有电梯
Shure's GF: There's an elevator here.
Shure的女友: 救命啊
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure:  你是不是觉得我吵
Shure: Am I bothering you?
Shure的女友: 不是你知道我现在有一种什么样的感觉
Shure's GF: No, do you know what I'm feeling right now?
Shure:   什么
Shure: What?
Shure的女友: 我感觉我在峨眉山
Shure's GF: I feel like I'm at Emei Mountain.
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Shure的女友: 我被那疯猴子缠上了
Shure's GF: I've been pestered by a crazy monkey.
Shure:   哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  你怎么能这么比喻我
Shure: How can you compare me like that?
Shure:  无语峨眉猴子
Shure: Speechless, Emei monkey.
Shure:  孰美君美甚
Shure: Who is more beautiful, you or me?
Shure:  猴子何能欺君业
Shure: How can a monkey deceive you?
Shure:  哈哈哈怎么了
Shure: Hahaha, what's wrong?
Shure:  振作一点人类
Shure: Pull yourself together, human.
Shure:  妈都的命也是命啊
Shure: A mother's life is a life too.
Shure:  别哭
Shure: Don't cry.
Shure的女友: 我们往前走
Shure's GF: Let's move forward.
Shure:  前面一定有路
Shure: There's definitely a path ahead.
Shure的女友: 你先松开
Shure's GF: Let go first.
Shure的女友: 妈妈妈妈不让我跟猴子玩
Shure's GF: Mom, mom told me not to play with monkeys.
Shure:  啊怎么
Shure: Ah, why?
Shure:   这么都都不让跟跟你们玩对不起
Shure: Everyone doesn't want to play with you, sorry.
Shure的女友: 妈妈妈妈不我跟你玩
Shure's GF: Mom, mom told me not to play with you.
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Heh heh.
Shure:  现在直接目标锁定成一个了是吗
Shure: So now we're directly targeting just one person, right?
Shure:  你你我
Shure: You, you, me.
Shure的女友: 是啊
Shure's GF: Yeah
Shure:  妈不告诉你
Shure: Mom didn't tell you
Shure:  认真点吗哈哈
Shure: Be serious, haha
Shure的女友: 那妈妈说的不是你
Shure's GF: That's not what Mom said about you
Shure:  那那照片是
Shure: Then whose picture is that?
Shure的女友: 不知道不知道p的吧
Shure's GF: I don't know, maybe photoshopped?
Shure:  那是修博吗难道
Shure: Is that Shurebo?
Shure的女友: 什么东西
Shure's GF: What's that?
Shure:  你不知道
Shure: You don't know
Shure:  我还有一个同卵双胞胎弟弟吗
Shure: I have an identical twin brother?
Shure:  叫修伯哇
Shure: Named Shurebo
Shure的女友：哇
Shure's GF: Wow
Shure:  比我高
Shure: Taller than me
Shure的女友: 哇
Shure's GF: Wow
Shure:  比我帅
Shure: More handsome than me
Shure的女友: 哇
Shure's GF: Wow
Shure:  比我身体好
Shure: Healthier than me
Shure的女友: 哇
Shure's GF: Wow
Shure的女友: 走到那个位置然后撞人了
Shure's GF: I walked to that spot and bumped into someone
Shure的女友: 这一撞撞了俩
Shure's GF: I bumped into two people
Shure:  撞一对是吗
Shure: You bumped into a couple?
Shure的女友: 没看见不是
Shure's GF: Didn't see, did I?
Shure的女友: 他那边没开灯
Shure's GF: His lights weren't on
Shure的女友: 我真的我一点看不见
Shure's GF: I really couldn't see at all
Shure的女友: 然后我就撞上去
Shure's GF: So I just bumped into them
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure的女友: 我还特地确认了一下
Shure's GF: I even double-checked
Shure的女友: 那里面应该没有人
Shure's GF: There shouldn't be anyone there
Shure的女友: 我可以走这条路
Shure's GF: I could walk that way
Shure的女友: 然后撞上去
Shure's GF: And then I bumped into them
Shure:  那你撞到人说对不起了吗
Shure: Did you say sorry after bumping into them?
Shure:  你忘了告五人是怎么告诉我们的吗
Shure: Did you forget how The Last Goodbye taught us?
Shure:  撞到人要说
Shure: When you bump into someone, you should say
Shure:  要说
Shure: You should say
Shure:  对不起
Shure: Sorry
Shure的女友: 你看我
Shure's GF: Look at me
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈哈
Shure's GF: Hahaha
Shure:  嘿嘿
Shure: Hehe
Shure:  你要干嘛
Shure: What are you going to do?
Shure:  兄弟
Shure: Bro
Shure:  你好香
Shure: You smell nice
Shure的女友：你几号变态
Violet: What's your number, pervert?
Shure:  嘿嘿你怎么知道
Shure: Haha, how did you know?
Shure:  困了不想写了
Shure: I'm tired, I don't want to write anymore
Shure的女友: 可以啊明天拿个空白的PPT
Violet: Sure, just bring a blank PPT tomorrow
Shure的女友：过去开始你的prime
Violet: And start your prime
Shure:  我给他来一种新式的PPT
Shure: I'll make a new style of PPT for him
Shure:  我我们原来英语课有那个presentation嘛
Shure: In our English class, we had a presentation
Shure:  然后看我们这页空白的
Shure: And look, our page is blank
Shure的女友：看我么你这一页空白的
Violet: Look, your page is blank
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then
Shure:  娱乐团的同学
Shure: Students from the entertainment group
Shure的女友: 然后我就要开始给你介绍
Violet: Then I'll start to introduce
Shure的女友: 我这页空白的
Violet: What's written on this blank page
Shure的女友: 上面写了什么
Violet: Only smart people can see it
Shure的女友: 只有聪明的人才能看到他
Shure:  好像在侮辱安迪的智商
Shure: It's like insulting Andy's intelligence
Shure的女友: 皇帝的新PPT
Violet: The Emperor's new PPT
Shure:   哈哈你这梗好到哪去了
Shure: Haha, where did you get this joke from?
Shure的女友: 很好啊
Violet: It's good, right?
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure的女友：那当然啦
Violet: Of course
Shure:  记住了没
Shure: Remember it?
Shure:  这是好梗
Shure: It's a good joke